et comment il est jeune
c'est surtout sa voix déjà apprécié
lorsque vous manqués dame qu'il arrive à
tout vous avez aimé comme ça c'est tout
l'arrivée d'un nouveau prêtre dans une
petite villa passe rarement inaperçu
surtout s'il est charismatique léon
morin hommes d'église séduisant et d'art
ni communistes athées deux personnages
que tout semble opposer
il ya quelque chose lors du suspense
amoureux et intentions vraiment qu'une
tension amoureuse
c'est une sur quelle voie peut prendre
l'amour pour s'exprimer
comment commandes de personnes doivent
se rencontrer quand les interdits sont
absolus en question c'est une séveran
qu'est ce qu'est l'amour parce que c'est
un amour qui doit être terrestre à ce
que l'amour qui doit être autrement
il tape appareils différents au début
j'ai mes hanches mali comme tous ses
semblables ce qui vous laisse quelqu'un
à mettre à genoux une adaptation du
roman de béatrice beck mûri par le
cinéaste depuis 20 ans contrairement aux
livres plus centré sur le prêtre le film
se veut un portrait de femme incarnée
par marine vacth ce qui m'a vraiment
intéressé c'est un débiteur de la d 24
ans à l'époque
c'est une immense maturité et une
qualité d'écouté remarquable et je me
suis dit pour un film cas autant de
textes qui slame joutes verbales le fait
qu'elle puisse autant écouter dès le
premier rendez vous quand je lui parlais
du rôle et tout ça je crois qu'elle
écoutait qu'une attention énorme
j'ai le sentiment que marine vacth et
romain duris a fonctionné parfaitement
il était totalement harmonieux ils ont
trouvé tout de suite le teint peau de
leurs échanges et ça a été un tournage
de ce point de vue là qu'ils avaient une
forme de grâce une élégance qui se
retrouvent sur grand écran les deux
protagonistes nous une relation à la
fois complice et complexe un drame
d'époque sur fond d'occupation allemande
à découvrir en salles le 8 mars
ce qui s'est passé
on dira que c'est le diable qui vous
avez un croche patte